ce matin je me suis senti un peu mal je
vais vous dire pourquoi je vous raconter
toute l'histoire
j'ai même pris des notes parce que tu
vois là je sais ça m'a touché je vous
dire déjà dans le dossier dont on va
parler de patrice carteron c'est le
boxeur qui a posté un long message sur
facebook pour s'en prendre à mesnel la
candidate de the voice qui a quitté
l'émission après la polémique donc de
ses tweets et franchement ça m'a tout
match a été loin patrice voilà il est
elle un peu loin ouais ouais un peu loin
au passage il a été violent et je crois
qu'on témoin simenel elle souhaite
prendre du recul elle est déterminée à
devenir artiste
elle se repose c'est ce qu'a dit donc
selon son avocat elle veut venir à une
réalité plus ordinaire elle était prof
d'anglais mais dell 1 voilà et je vous
dirai ce matin la production l'a appelé
venez nous dire ce que vous en pensez
vous aussi chez vous et vous allez me
dire quelle aurait été votre sentiment
voici donc lionel stade le président de
la société la plèbe dit voilà on
aimerait bien que tu viennes sur le
plateau parce que voilà on aimerait que
tu viens d'expliquer que voilà est-ce
que tu as envie de venir sur touche pas
à mon poste et lui a dit elle a passé de
longues minutes avec lui au téléphone
elle voulait s'expliquer et elle m'a dit
voilà moi j'étais fan de tpm pays et le
soir où ils ont parlé de moi j'étais
devant mon poste et j'ai été dévasté par
ce qui a été dit je vous donne son
message en voilà elle a été dévastée par
ce qui était dit elle ni qu'aujourd'hui
à cause de cette aventure the voice et
donc de ce qui s'est passé elle était
prof d'anglais elle peut plus exercer
comme prof d'anglais aujourd'hui à jouer
devant voilà parce qu'elle a des soucis
elle peut plus exercer comme trop en
anglais elle voulait juste être artiste
elle dit voilà qu'elle regrette bien
entendu ces tweets que c'était c'est
qu'il ya deux ans voilà et qu' elle est
là aujourd'hui aller elle est vraiment
très très mal et que et voilà elle nous
a dit voilà que c'était aussi mon poste
qu'il y avait beaucoup parlé de la
polémique mais c'est vrai que tout le
monde en a parlé c'est vrai que tpm pc
les missions à forte résonance dit la
vérité
et voilà moi quand j'ai su qu'elle était
vraiment hyper mal comme ça alors je
suis contre ce qu'elle a mis comme tweet
vous le savez vraiment
vraiment je je je je les dis ici j'ai
vraiment dit que je ne cautionnais pas
du tout mais c'est vrai que ça m'a fait
beaucoup beaucoup de peine bah jolie
fille d'à turner ça va actia elle émue
elle en train de mourir ça va il est
vrai bien mais ça ne m'arrivera des
anneaux j'aimerais pas du tout hein pas
du tout cette émission ça rigolait il
aimerait bien mais ça n'arrive pas alors
on essaie lille pour revenir à sa une
mais neil voilà ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup
et me voilà ce que m'a dit ce que m'a
rapporté lionel stan qu'est ce que vous
en pensez y si franchement est-ce que
vous parce que je me dis est ce que les
médias parce que et nous nous aussi y
compris est-ce qu'on a été trop loin
dans cette polémique est ce qu'on en a
trop fait nous les autres médias parce
que tout le monde dans la partie est et
sur toutes les chaînes on va pas se
mentir
voilà on n'est pas les seuls
responsables mais on est aussi
responsable
est ce qu'on en a trop fait et est-ce
qu'on a peut-être voilà gâcher la vie de
deux domaines elle est peut-être la
carrière d'artiste moi je ne nie pas
notre responsabilité ici et j'en suis
fier c'est vrai qu'on a été pressé pter
en matière du débat mais fallait-il ou
non la virée et beaucoup d'entre nous
moi notamment dit il faut absolument la
virée du real a écrit des horreurs elle
a écrit des heures et des heures après
sur après moi ce que j'ai toujours dit
c'est que ça l'a dépassée c'est de
l'ordre du symbole c'est parce qu'elle a
écrit ça que la personne mais neil
souffrent et je sais que pour elle c'est
très dur
moi si elle venait ici pour discuter
avec nous de manière extrêmement sereine
et sans agressivité
moi je trouve ce sera un débat très
intéressant et voilà on peut pas nier je
vous dis non nourrir ses tweets il était
voilà c'était c'était vraiment une
horreur et on peut même on peut pas les
défendre c'est inné indéfendable aulas
d'ici mais nous voilà je vous dis dans
cette émission vraiment moi je vous dis
je parle toujours avec mon coeur est ici
on est tous vraiment très sensible et
quand quelqu'un est vraiment très triste
et quand quelqu'un leur au téléphone et
vous dit que vous lui avez voilà que
cette affaire voice ça lui a gâché sa
carrière et sa vie
bien sûr forcément ça nous fait quelque
chose et on parle on a tous fait des
erreurs
jean pas se mentir la cnra s'intègre
avec une option d'un an nous arrivait de
dire des conneries on s'est excusé où on
avait voilà et c'est vrai que on a on
dit
jours ici dans cette émission on a le
droit à une deuxième chance qu'on a le
droit voilà essayer de se rattraper et
c'est vrai que voilà même si c'est
indéfendable ce qu'elle a fait moi ça
m'a un peu touché voilà de la voix
rauque florine elle pourrait venir c'est
là j'espère et en plus je vous le dis
elle était hyper fan de l'émission
oui je suis d'accord c'est le premier
c'est que même façon que parfois on fait
des amalgames à la con dans ce cas
précis effectivement je pense que c'est
c'est terrible pour elle parce que et a
des conséquences mais c'est elle qui
trinque pour plein de raisons
mais c'est vrai que dans sa dent dans la
symbolique on pouvait personne pouvait
pardonner entre et à pardonner laisser
passer ces tweets qui sont pour moi
totalement avant de la main dans le
regrette effectivement on a
effectivement beaucoup parlé de la fin
on a fait un jour on est revenu dessus
on a été assez vrai qu'à chaque fois on
en mettait plein de couches et je
comprends que pour elle en tant
qu'individu ce soit terrible maintenant
dans la symbolique de ce qui a été
twitté je pense qu'on pouvait que dire
ce que parent je ne pouvais que dire ce
que j'ai dit regardez
mais vous comprenez même si je sais bien